excusez-moi série après le ping pong
c'est pas la semaine vous allez perdre
que tout le monde je ne gagne la gamme
après deux échecs pas vous en a vu d
échec pourtant vous êtes toujours à la
télé ce côté artiste showman on le voit
sur scène vous savez le côté artiste au
chômage hachey d'autres faire une
annonce quany voix parti vivre en
angleterre quoi je vous dis franchement
y'a bien qu'en valeur vous aidez vous
faites quelque chose de me regarder
ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est vous c'est
moi parce que je me dis bientôt je
pourrai le faire et il me regardera de
chez lui il a dit me mo mais bref c'est
ça c'est vrai que c'était pour
rapprocher toi on dirait mon frère est
content de te voir
merci émis à 100 millions d'euros presse
et les murs
[Applaudissements]
la cour a tort
filmé pendant la pub l'arrêt oui ça fait
des victimes triple agression est passé
au sol martin lorsqu'on parle de
violence partie car vous ce que c'est
bien sympa la de manger des sandwichs
mais tu sais les durs je vais lire ces
pages si tu montes ses tubes ou fait
autant de sandwiches que tu lisais de
bouquins je peux dire qu'aujourd'hui tu
présenteras faut un post of conan
monsieur bolloré c'est pas le pape sera
le directeur général et président de la
chaîne où le traité d'abruti qu'est ce
que vous faites quelqu'un me traite de
brut et puisque vous faites je le
connais bien je regarde la centrale a
également fait tripper exactement touche
pas à mon passé lorsque qui fait déjà
alors je te jure que c'est vrai je te
kiffe est alors que lui tu connaissais
pas le chômage est plus grande quand il
le faut qu'on met ce que le vrai
compostelle
[Applaudissements]
on dit que tu es là
monde j'aimerais que vous retourniez sur
nrj 12 mois que c'est catastrophique si
tu vas faire qui pour toi ça te t-bag
alors au gré des quatuors empêcher toi